THE REACTITI ICE HEEFRM'S
TAGE THOMPSON WITH THE SHOT AND
HE'S NOT ABLE TO HANDLE THE
PUCK.OORSTEP
TIES THE GAME FOR THE PREDATORS
WITH 15:28 TO GO IN
FRONT AND IT'S IN THE NET.
THE PUCK CAME TO THE CORNER IN
FRONT OF THE NET.
YOU'VE GOT TO KEEPP
CODY EAKIN.
EAKIN WITH A REBOUND, AND SAROS.
HE TRIES TO LEAVE IT.
A
UP
WHEN HE WAS HERE.
TAGE THOMPSONT THERE.
HE TRIES STOPPING IT.
HE CAN'T HANDLE IT.
IT'S IN THE  SCORES.
BENNING LET THE S THE TRAFFIC. .
THE PREDATORS HAVE TIED THE GAME
AS
DROP PASS TO DUCHENE.
HE ANDERSON AND THEN THES HE TR
MAKE A PLAY.
JOKIHARJU.
JOHANSEN FIRES WIDE.
HE HOLDS HIT GROUN
PREDATORS WILL BRING IT BA
ANDRE.
NICE JOB HITTING THE PUCK DOWN
IN THE CORNER.
THIS IS KREBS.
THE FEED FROM
IT'S BACK TO DAHLIN, TO THE NET.
IT DOESN'T GET
GOAL LINE ASUT OF THE CORNER.
ASPLUND SENDS IT ACRCRGO.
JOSI WILL SEND ITOT TIME LEFT I
THE SEASON.
WE CAN PUSH A LITTLE
HE STROKES IT IN BEHIND THETO T.
SKINNER TOWIDE.
GRANLUND FAR BOARD.
AHAND AT ANDERSON.
CLEARED.
SENT B
JOHANSSON AGAINST EAKIN.
THE PUCK IS DOWN, AWAY